on this episode of the pop culture
decoded show it's all Breaking Bad we
look at how Breaking Bad relates to
westerns and the Godfather we dissect an
iconic scene and we'll break down a new
teaser for the El Camino movie
[Music]
with the release of the upcoming
Breaking Bad movie El Camino we wanted
to take a look back at the original
series and dissect a few scenes Nate
what do you want to talk about today so
I brought in the episode 11 from season
four crawlspace it's one of my favorite
episodes
because so many things happen and also
technically I think it's definitely
something worth talking about it is very
very interesting and before we talk
about I think we need to sort of talk
about the cinematographer I think he's
played such an important role Yeah right
so how I want to talk about this is
according to him there are three big
influences so when he was filming
Breaking Bad one is surprisingly
Godfather it's it's very different
visually but actually there's a lot in
common and I think it's especially
evident in a lot of interior scenes so
we're gonna look at this scene from
crawlspace it's when Walter is talking
to Tyrus but I mostly want to talk about
lighting here okay so what Godfather is
very famous for is it was the very first
film that did a very unique sort of
lighting which was sort of the very
minimal overhead lighting and if you
actually see especially in a lot of the
meth lab scene is that they actually use
a lot of overhead lights if you actually
see the overall lighting into place
there's a lot of lamps right off you can
see see a lot of that and especially if
you look at right here mm-hmm
you can see shadows a lot of shadows
here yeah IRA shadows which is very kind
of peculiar because a lot of TV shows
and movies they light the face a lot
yeah also do use that's why the use of
reflectors to sort of bounce the light
off but actually what's funny is instead
of bouncing the light onto the face they
bounce it off and then it sort of gets
dispersed here a lot of lighting is sort
of just on their body and not their face
and what it does is it adds sort of a
complexity to the lighting you know and
I think a lot of problem that I have
with modern television is everything is
so well lit Breaking Bad uses
of different sort of shadows and lights
and there's definitely a contrast to it
and also yeah if you look at it a lot
you can definitely snow it right there
especially in the close-up scenes of the
faces yeah you can definitely see sort
of a line for me the light is obviously
coming from here there's no direct light
coming on to his face yeah you see the a
line right right so it sort of divides
his face in half where one part of his
face is sort of lit up but another part
of his face is not yeah and that's
actually also something that Godfather's
sort of uses okay I'll buy it a little
differently so Godfather CeBIT ography
by Gordon Willis is a very important
figure in the history of sort of
cinematography also uses a lot of
shadows
and he was in a lot of ways well the
very first person to do this in sort of
like mainstream big cinema and how he
you said a lot is again used overhead
shots and that what it does is it puts a
lot of shadow near the eyes actually
there's a very funny story where someone
from the studio said you know I can't
see the eye like I can't see what's
happening and the director and the
Scimitar refer would say that it doesn't
really matter it's he really wanted to
focus sort of on the entire expression
of the face rather than the eye which is
usually how actors these days sort of
act using their eyes but he actually
really wanted to focus on using the
entire face to sort of act so the
lighting that you're talking about
really accentuates certain parts of his
face and gives it more depth you see
they're like the shadow is causing the
deepest blacks and really I can abyss
and really conveys his emotion his pain
right ah it really makes it more complex
because you have like places where it's
really well lit yeah and where it's half
lit and then we're sort of like very
darkly but yeah so it's like it does add
complexity and as you said depth so that
was it for me what do you want to talk
about Carter I want to talk about a
scene from season 3 episode 1 no mas
so in this scene the Salamanca cousins
are arriving from Mexico going across
the border
getting smuggled in in this truck full
of hay with some other immigrants I
wanted to talk about this scene right
here we get a great frame within a frame
so what I mean by that is cameras inside
the truck and you get this natural frame
of the back of the hay truck that points
your eye towards the action here now
that I'm just looking at the frame do
you know that ending scene in searchers
it's no they're like very sinister
yeah which has been very influential and
I'm seeing this resembles not a lot yet
so then as we continue here we go to a
very interesting shot and we get to this
giant wide shun eyes are looking at just
these small small figures in this vast
landscape so why do you think they chose
to go to this shot we're in a way sort
of turning away from the violence we're
taking a step back and looking at it and
you know sort of showing how this
violence is so meaningless how it's so
quick and when you look at it from far
away
it's just nothing when in fact if we had
a close-up it would have had a huge
impact
you know seeing this like intense moment
up close seeing the fear but it's
there's almost no emotion in this scene
that's what I'm getting I definitely
agree with that
it's clear that it's an average day for
them almost they've done this many times
that makes the violence even more brutal
because I you know for movies it's
always about what you imagine is worse
than what you actually see the
cinematographer actually singled this
shot out in a couple of interviews as
one of his favorites and what he said
was very often we'll use a wide shot
where everyone else in the world would
have used a close-up for example in
season three's opening episode that
drivers shot on the ground as opposed to
going to a great big close-up of a gun
and seeing that big thing burst into our
face we hear a tiny little pop we all
know what's happening and it makes us
want to see more that's the beauty of
these wide shots
so I thought that was another really
interesting point that he raised up that
the audience is trained by media and
probably by Breaking Bad as well that
they're gonna get this violence and get
you know a close-up of someone getting
shot they're sort of playing with our
expectation with our expectations and
also just a great shot of the the
composition of you know just a built-in
dichotomy between the beauty of the
scene and the violence and death that
the cousins are bringing so during the
Emmys the new teaser for El Camino job
it didn't seem like there was a lot but
it seemed like the fans were picking it
apart they actually found a surprising
number of sort of hints and clues um do
you notice anything yeah I did notice
something so let's take a look here so
first of all this is the El Camino that
Jesse escaped in after the last episode
of Breaking Bad
it's Todd's El Camino so right here
someone on reddit actually lightened the
image and found some of the same rock
formations in the background and found
out that it was actually the exact same
place where Jesse and Walt first cooked
which is also where Ozymandias took
place where Hank died and where Walt
buried his money and then on the radio
they're talking about nine bodies so we
took a look back at the finale to
confirm and it is eight Nazis that Walt
killed and then Walt himself so that
would be not nine so that's it for this
teaser but a full trailer actually came
out next day and our team here at
insider broke that down so if you want
to watch that check out our YouTube
channel that's it for today
we'll see you next time you know Studios
should really let the film makers do
their job yeah and not get in the way
yeah studios if your list of studios